I learned this the hard way Zac Ephron
admits he's had a rough go when it comes
to the people from his past in a world
where we swipe left and swipe right and
you meet people and friends come and go
you really should pay attention to who
you're with the American plotting my
escape here
ET spoke with the actor at the Tribeca
Film Festival premiere of his new movie
extremely wicked shockingly evil and
vile which chronicles the crimes of the
late serial killer Ted Bundy I'm very
happy that what Joe Berlin drew and I
set out to do which was to make a movie
about something that happened in real
life that wowed the world one story that
is very dark and hard to tell and make
it about the characters make it about
what really transpired how was Ted able
to completely mislead a nation like for
years like in the justice system at the
highest level he's a savant not to
celebrate the man that was my number one
goal was not to celebrate Ted Bundy or
his horrific acts the movies title is
accurate who the person is but it's not
what the movie itself is about
I think any anybody who is a first of
all homage is paid over and over to the
victims of Ted Bundy we are doing
everything we can and there's more to be
done for all of his victims I think we
should do more and I would like to Zak
also dished on the buzz over the film
it's always nice to be acknowledged for
any performance I I don't really read
reviews or anything like that
[Music]
[Applause]